economists predict decreasing customer
visits to both restaurants and retailers
will likely continue as concerns over
the delta variant and new restrictions
grow here's a look at where our state
falls and what's contributing to it
[Music]
top data's september edition of the
covet impact study analyzes gps tracking
data of some 12 million americans
tracking their visits to locations
across 45 different industries they
found nationwide spending across retail
and service is only down one percent
from where it was in july topped out as
ceo ben kaplan in general what we've
seen is that stores that have more
limited limited interactions things like
luxury goods have been doing better in
terms of maintaining their foot traffic
than other places new jersey delaware
and rhode island are the top three
states where people are currently
spending more at retail and service
businesses but nevada lands in the
bottom three where we've seen a 7.5
decrease in spending at retail and
service businesses since july kaplan
says the rise in the delta variant is a
direct factor the biggest
negative impact have been basically
places where people don't have control
over their in-person interactions so
gyms uh bars beauty salons um all of
those places have definitely been
affected in nevada more so than other
states